your night for that B7 pawn and for the  creation of some threads is on your mind  at all  owing HDX G5 must be ringing such alarm  bells in your mind  and this is actually where Richie  resigned uh let's just  recap on on the the winning line uh so  basically oh yeah  here  and the interesting part is I think C6  is the only mover that they're after  Queen B5 check I think everything else  allows white white back into the game  and might they actually even lose  but specifically c627 King E6 escapes  all checks  and The Rook H1 made does come in with  very obvious effect fantastic  yeah it is a stunning game but also a  very young characteristic Mistake by by  Richard because I think you know